these are funnier questions rapid fire
here we go uh the classic the classic
does size matter or is it more about
motion in the ocean
you know the motion the ocean thing is
really silly because it's really about
the guy the connection the intimacy the
trust the feeling it's not about either
it's women focus so little on the penis
in general we just want you to be a good
dude because you can be with a dude
that's smaller not even that hot but the
connection was so good the nbc is so
good so
um size is great for when you're in that
situation because then you get the
paycheck but oh size of the paycheck
motion in the ocean is such a weird size
the size of the wallet is more important
than size of the penis
i would say so and today there it is in
today's world how long should sex last
for on average
for civilians like unchained
you know i asked my civilian friends
this i think it usually they say an
average of 10 minutes but maybe like a
little bit more if it's like a vacation
maybe 20 minutes if there's been some
like the guy takes the blue pill you
know what have you if there's some
viagra maybe longer but is it like 10
minutes right because it's set where
you're going for an average or how long
it should be how long should it be
amber amber love i know that my mom is
watching but um pretend you're in berlin
for a
amberlynn is speaking not your daughter
um i would like from from foreplay to
finish like 40 minutes that would be
fantastic that's ideal right david do
you have that kind of time i got [ __ ] to
do what are you talking about
um yeah cut down the middle 20
no because she's asking for a nice bit
of foreplay every time okay i'm just
kidding oh wait wait no no listen 40
minutes every time
yeah babes aggressive we got them anyway
keeping it moving because this is rapid
fire it was a quickie my turn my
we're gonna get there hold on we're
gonna get there amber for the right okay
by the way what's the most amount you've
ever made for one scene
oh i don't really want to answer yeah
okay a lot a lot yeah more than six
figures
no okay all right thank you for that for
the right price is there anything that
is off limits
um i don't like choking violent scenes
graphic stuff that i don't do in my real
life i don't want to be somebody's
stepmom or real mom i don't want to get
into the incestual [ __ ] for any amount
of money so i guess that answers that
everything else is fine why are all
these women
getting stuck in the washing machine
is this real no the no this in porn
no you're not familiar with the washing
machine
i know it's disgraceful right it's stuck
in the washing machine and the toilet
and the toilet i haven't seen it in the
toilet okay swirlies
[Music]